and the question is how complex is the
uh
the the range of possibilities that
might happen in the driving task right
that's still is that to you still an
open problem of how difficult is driving
like philosophically speaking
do you all the time you've worked on
driving do you understand how hard
driving is yeah driving is really hard
because it has to do with the
predictions of all these other agents in
the theory of mind and you know what
they're going to do and are they looking
at you are they are they looking what
are they thinking yeah there's a lot
that goes there at the at the full tail
off you know the the expansion of the
nines that we have to be comfortable
with eventually
the final problems are of that form I
don't think those are the problems that
are very common I think eventually
they're important but it's like really
in the tail end in the tail and the rare
edge cases
from the vision perspective what are the
toughest parts of the vision problem of
driving
um
well basically the sensor is extremely
powerful but you still need to process
that information
and so going from brightnesses of these
pixel values to hey here the
three-dimensional world is extremely
hard and that's what the neural networks
are fundamentally doing and so
um the difficulty really is in just
doing an extremely good job of
engineering the entire pipeline the
entire data engine having the capacity
to train these neural Nets having the
ability to evaluate the system and
iterate on it uh so I would say just
doing this in production at scale is
like the hard part it's an execution
problem so the data engine but also the
um the sort of deployment of the system
such that has low latency performance so
it has to do all these steps yeah for
the neural map specifically just making
sure everything fits into the chip on
the car yeah and uh you have a finite
budget of flops that you can perform and
uh and memory bandwidth and other
constraints and you have to make sure it
flies and you can squeeze in as much
compute as you can into the tiny what
have you learned from that process
because it maybe that's one of the
bigger like new things coming from a
research background
where there's there's a system that has
to run under heavily constrained
resources right has to run really fast
what what kind of insights have you uh
learned from that yeah I'm not sure if
it's if there's too many insights you're
trying to create a neural Nest that will
fit in what you have available and
you're always trying to optimize it and
we talked a lot about it on the AI day
and uh basically the the triple
backflips that the team is doing to make
sure it all fits and utilizes the engine
uh so I think it's extremely good
engineering
um and then there's also all kinds of
little insights peppered in on how to do
it properly